britz mas trouve à dallas willy
kayakistes une marina
le 22 juin 1941 l'allemagne à lancer
l'invasion surprise de l'urss
déclenchant ce qui allait prendre en
russie le nom de grande guerre
patriotique un avantage significatif en
nombre et en équipements militaires a
permis aux troupes nazies de gagner de
vastes territoires sans grande
résistance et en quelques mois de se
retrouver aux portes de moscou
mais après une série de batailles
féroces et grâce à une résistance
imprévue du peuple soviétique les
allemands n'ont jamais pu entrer dans la
ville et ont été forcés de battre en
retraite
[Musique]
les températures glaciales le manque de
nourriture et d'eau ont transformé la
ville en enfer au milieu des
innombrables mort de la famine et des
souffrances les gens entendaient le sont
persistants du métronome de leningrad
[Musique]
retransmis à la radio ce son est devenu
le battement de coeur virtuelle de la
ville est un symbole de résistance
populaire sur le front sud la bataille
de stalingrad allait devenir l'une des
batailles les plus sanglantes de la
guerre
au bout de cinq mois de combats le
massacre infernal a pris fin
[Musique]
cette victoire difficile a été un
tournant de la guerre portant un dur
coup au moral des troupes nazies et
prouvant qu'elle n'était pas invincible
en 1944 l'urss avait repoussé
l'agresseur de tous ces territoires et
commencer à avancer sur berlin
alors que les forces anglo américaine
mettait en place un deuxième front les
troupes soviétiques ont pu libérer
d'autres pays après la chute de berlin
en mai 1945 l'allemagne a capitulé
mais le prix à payer pour la victoire a
été très élevé plus de la moitié étaient
des civils
le 9 mai a été déclaré jour de la
victoire pour commémorer ce grand
sacrifice et rappeler les horreurs dont
la guerre menace ceux qui se battent
pour leur existence
[Musique]